très bien avec toutes mes excuses pour
Madame lequé Tubiana parce que nous
avons pris du retard avec l'installation
de la Commission et la première audition
nous allons entamer tout de suite nous
allons écouter donc maintenant entendre
madame Corine lequeré présidente du Haut
Conseil pour le climat et Madame
Laurence Tubiana membre du Haut Conseil
pour le climat pardon madame lecléré
vous êtes climatologue professeur en
sciences du changement climatique à
université d'istanglia où vous dirigez
un groupe de recherche sur les émissions
et puit de carbone vous assurez la
présidence du HCC organisme indépendant
chargé d'évaluer l'action publique en
matière de climat et sa cohérence avec
les engagements européens internationaux
de la France depuis la loi énergie
climat de
2019 madame Laurence Tubiana vous êtes
membbrre du haconseil pour le climat et
présidente et directrice exécutive de la
Fondation européenne pour le climat vous
avez été ambassadrice chargée des
négociations sur le changement
climatique et représentante spéciale
pour la COP 20 21
pardon avant de vous laisser la parole
pour un propos introductif d'une
quinzaine de minutes à vous deux il me
revient de vous indiquer que cette
audition est diffusée en direct et en
différé sur le site internet du Sénat la
vidéo sera le cas échéant diffusé sur
les réseaux sociaux puis consultable en
vidéo à la demande elle fera l'objet
d'un compte-rendu
public je
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête est passible
des peines prévues aux articles 434 13
14 15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller de
3 à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et de 45000 à
100000 € d'amende avant de vous céder la
parole je vous invite à nous préciser si
vous détenez des intérêts de toute
nature dans le groupe Total ennergie ou
dans l'un de ses concurrents dans le
secteur de
l'énergie non non répondez pardon mais
au micro non je ne Laurence tu bien je
ne détiens aucun aucun lien avec
l'entreprise totale ou ses concurrents
Corine lequerri je ne détient aucun lien
avec l'entreprise ou ses concurrents
très bien je vous invite maintenant à
prêter serment de dire toute la vérité r
que la vérité en levant la main droite
et en disant seulement
je le jure je le jure je le jure merci
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs donc le Haut Conseil pour le
climat est composé de d'experts
d'experts de l'énergie l'expert du
climat comme Laurence tbiana et moi-même
c'est un organisme indépendant qui est
chargé d'évaluer l'action publique en
matière de climat et ça ça inclut sa
cohérence avec les engagements européens
et internationaux de la France France en
particulier l'accord de Paris et
l'atteinte de la neutralité carbone en
euh le HCC rend un app un rapport de
progrès chaque année sur le respect de
la trajectoire de baisse des émissions
au regard des des objectifs de la France
mais aussi qui inclut la mise en œuvre
et l'efficacité des politiques publiques
pour réduire les émissions
euh développer les pu de carbone réduire
l'emprun de carbone et développer
l'adaptation au changement climatiqu
le gouvernement doit répondre à ce
rapport dans les 6 mois devant le
Parlement et devant le cise et donc le
Sénat s'est emparé de nos rapports à
plusieurs reprises et je l'en
remercie aujourd'hui je vais donner un
aperçu dans mon propos liminire des
constats du dernier rapport et des
évolutions
actuelles tout d'abord dans ce premier
rapport dans ce rapport 2023 nous avons
fait un constat sur les impacts cl
climatique qui
s'aggrave en France et en en regardant
les impacts de l'année 2022 qui ont été
nombreux en terme de vagu de chaleur de
sécheresse qui ont influencé et affecté
la production agricole la production
électrique en France avec des impacts
qui ont dépassé les capacités de gestion
de crise actuel ce qui démontre bien
l'intensification du réchauffement
climatique qui suit les trajectoires qui
est causé par les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre humaines et ces impacts
vont continuer à
s'intensifier tant que la neutralité
carbone ne sera pas atteinte au niveau
mondial donc les objectifs climatiques
sont vraiment importants pour ça bien
sûr avec l'adaptation en parallèle qui
peut réduire les impacts mais qui ne
peut pas complètement les effacer euh
donc la situation en France est la
suivante donc la France elle a une
politique climatique les émissions de
gaz à effet de ser diminuent la France
fait partie de 18 au moins de 18 pays au
niveau global où les émissions de gaz à
effets diminuent à la fois les émissions
territoriales donc qui sont sur le pays
mais aussi l'emprun carbon de la France
donc la France n'est pas seule dans ses
actions climatiques au contraire ces
actions climatiques sont enclenché dans
pratiquement tous les pays
mondiaux en France la les la les
émissions de gaz à effet-s se
poursuivent à une à une réduction
d'environ 1,9 % par année en moyenne sur
les dernières années euh la France elle
a une stratégie nationale bas carbone
qui atteint son objectif de 250 de
neutralité carbone en 2050 mais elle a
en particulier établi des budgets
carbones à tous les 5 ans qui permet euh
de mettre la trajectoire de baisse en
émission sur une trajectoire qui est
prévisible
pour l'ensemble des acteurs et qui est
au bon rythme qui nous assure de
d'arriver au but et du coup pour les
budgets carbones le premier budget
carbone qui avait été établi sur la
période 2015-218 a été
dépassé pour le deuxème budget carbone
qui est en cours
2019-2023 sur les émissions simplement
les émissions brutes le budget carbone
est en voie d'être respecté mais
malheureusement euh parce que les puits
de carbone forestiers donc les forêts
qui sont fragilisées par le
réchauffement climatique les puits de
carbone forestiers diminue quand on
prend l'objectif du du budget carbone
qui inclut à la fois les émissions et le
stockage de carbone dans les sols et les
forêts du coup ce cet objectif est en
voie d'être dépassé donc la France elle
est pas sur la bonne trajectoire à
l'heure actuelle euh l'objectif de 2030
lui aussi et est apporté demain mais à
condition que on voit une accélération
de la baisse en émission dans tous les
secteurs émetteurs et cette accélération
elle doit elle implique de pratiquement
doubler la baisse en émission de la
France par rapport à la période récente
entre 2019 et
2022 et du coup l'objectif 2030 est
important pour vraiment avoir cette
trajectoire à la baisse et donc les
rythmes de baisse actuels sont
insuffisants le Haut Conseil pour le
climat a analysé à développer une
méthode d'évaluation de l'action
publique pour voir si
l'appareil de l'État était était en
route en place pour justement enclencher
cette
accélération cette méthode d'évaluation
inclut cinq composantes la première il
s'agit de la stratégie donc le volet
stratégique c'est le mieux développé on
a en France la stratégie nationale bas
carbone on a la programmation
pluri-annuelle de l'énergie il y a de
nombreux documents stratégiques et de
plans d'action qui ont été publiés on
pourrait avoir plus de cohérence et de
l'alignement de ces stratégies parce que
à l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas ce n'est
pas assuré mais cette stratégie elle est
en construction et elle est déjà bien
avancée elle est claire pour les acteur
il y a pas de
surprise et on sait depuis longtemps que
on que la France va répondre à à au
défis climatique suivant la trajectoire
établie dans la stratégie nationale bas
carbone dans notre méthode d'évaluation
le deuxè le deuxème volet c'est
effectivement la politique économique
qui soutient tout ça donc là on parle du
financement sur plusieurs années pour
être à la hauteur des enjeux le
financement
le budget de l'État on parle de la
politique commerciale et on parle aussi
de la politique de l'emploi et ce qu'on
a constater dans notre rapport avec
l'approfondissement en particulier de
secteur du transport et des logements
c'est que la stratégie actuelle n'est
pas accompagnée d'une politique
économique d'ampleur permettant de
déclencher
l'accélération
nécessaire le un soutien supplémentaire
et nécessaire déjà au niveau du
financement pour financer les
mesures les mesures nécessaires mais en
plus on a vraiment besoin d'avoir une
vision d'ensemble pour justement aligner
les décisions macro-économique qui
concernent qui concerne toute la
politique de l'État avec la trajectoire
vers la neutralité
carbone trème élément les freins et
leviers donc on parle ici de tous les
obstacles qui peuvent accélérer appuyer
ou ou ralentir par exemple la recherche
et le développement par exemple
l'infrastructure l'infrastructure de
recherche pour les voitures électriques
c'est un exemple typique il y en a
beaucoup il y en a 15 simplement dans le
secteur des transports ce qui donne une
idée du travail à accomplir on voit que
le gouvernement a identifié la plupart
des mesures sont identifiées mais
beaucoup sont abordées de manière
ponctuelle par exemple avec des appels
d'offre à relativement court terme et la
maîtrise de la demande fait l'objet de
assez peu de mesures alors que l'offre
au consommateurs elle est elle très très
carbonée euh 4e point la transition
juste les politiques climatiques à
l'heure actuelle pèsent davantage sur
les ménages les modest les plus modestes
et les entreprises les plus modestes
malgré le fait que on fait euh alors
l'heure actuelle des efforts de
compensation euh le l'examen euh du coup
le le le problème identifié c'est que
l'offre actuelle elle est inadéquate on
a une offre qui est trop chère qui est
pas adapté à la culture actuelle qui est
pas assez mise en avant deux exemples le
premier c'est celui des véhicules très
lourds qui qui sont pas abordables pour
les ménages et les seconds c'est celui
de l'alimentation très carbonée où on
valorise très peu les produits
alimentaires bac carbon il y a une
limite de capacitard de de réponse
desménag qui s'ajoute à une forte une
forte inflation le dernier point je vais
pas en parler c'est celui de
l'adaptation mais pour dire que
l'adaptation c'est un prérequis en fait
à à aux mesures à l'implémentation des
mesures
d'atténuation je vais peut-être
peut-être m'arrêtez là je vois si
Laurence tu veux ajouter des points
introductifs avec plaisir monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs pour essayer aussi de
compléter ce que vient de dire Corine
lequeré par rapport à la question qui
nous est
posé du rôle de l'entreprise totale et
de la diplomatie française et de de
l'action de l'État vis-à-vis de
l'entreprise simplement pour rappeler
que nous sommes par ailleurs un pays qui
importe beaucoup de pétrole et de gaz
toujours hein 28 % euh dans notre de
pétrole dans notre bouquet énergétique
on en produit comme vous le savez très
peu 16 % de gaz naturel et les
importations de pétrole ont augmenté de
20 % en 2022 donc nous ne sommes encore
loin
d'avoir évidemment un mix énergétique
qui euh soit décarboné comme vient de le
souligner Corine lekereré peut-être un
élément sur l'entreprise totale et son
rôle mondial très important c'est une
très grande entreprise comme nous le
savons euh 90 19 % des activités de
production de Total énergie en 2022
repose sur le pétrole et le gaz c'est la
deuxième plus grande entreprise
expansionistes des énergies fossiles
dans le monde car il y a un grand nombre
de projets d'exploration de nouveaux
champs de pétrole et de gaz dans dans
toutes les régions du monde Amérique
latine Asie et Afrique euh c'est la
firme qui a approuvé le plus de nouveaux
projets pétroliers gazers en 2022 en
particulier en Ouganda en Tanzanie le
projet le plus émetteur en particulier
plus spécifiquement est un projet
d'extraction de gaz de schiste en
Argentine euh qui est tout à fait
important le le gaz de schiste comme
vous le savez est un grand émetteur
aussi non seulement de carbone mais de
méthane qui est un gaz particulièrement
dangereux puisqu'il r il il est il a sa
capacité de de réchauffement est est
plus importante que le CO2 même si sa
durée de vie dans l'atmosphère est plus
courte alors euh c'est sur ces 33
projets super émetteurs 19 sont situés à
moins de 50 km d'une zone de
biodiversité protégée et 25 sont situés
dans des pays avec des régimes
effectivement qui qui posent des
questions sur un peu la représentation
des intérêts des populations alors
pourquoi cela c'est que le président
Macron notamment à Dubaï et je crois que
ça a été bien accueilli a rappelé
l'engagement de la France aux accords de
Paris et présenter un plan qui prévoit
de tourner la page du pétrole en 2045 et
celle du gaz en 2050 ce qui est conforme
aux objectifs européens de même le
président de la République a exprimé
vraiment vouloir prendre un visage
absolu pour sortir des énergies fossiles
et euh il est vrai que lorsqu'on regarde
euh notamment
euh les les analyses de l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie qui va
d'ailleurs très bientôt fêter son 50e
anniversaire Laue montre que tout cela
maintenir les températures en dessous de
2 degrés euh indépendamment même de de
conserver l'accord de l'objectif de
l'accord de Paris de 1 de5 de
réchauffement en moyenne implique de
cesser tous les nouveaux projets
d'exploration de de gaz et de pétrole
puisque il y en a suffisamment
aujourd'hui même pour dépasser comme on
le sait le le les de degr aujourd'hui
puisque nous sommes sur un scénario
aujourd'hui quand on prend toutes les
politiques qui est au-dessus de 2 degrés
5 donc le la la grande question c'est
comment mettre en cohérence une
entreprise très dynamique qui a pour
l'essentiel enfin qui n'est pas une
entreprise qui investi beaucoup dans les
énergies renouvelables c'est le cas
d'ailleurs de toutes les autres aussi et
que cela évidemment rentre en en
considération enfin je pense à aux
grandes entreprises privées
international mais c'est vrai aussi des
grandes entreprises nationales je pense
à Ramco à grands concurrents hein de
Total en moyenne les entreprises
pétrolières investissent moins de 2 % de
leurs investissements dans les énergies
renouvelable donc ils sont pas en voie
de diversification total n'est pas la
pire loin de là mais quand même elle
reste dans ses investissement très
modeste et c'est là que on peut voir un
un une une manière de réfléchir sur la
manière dont c'est encore une entreprise
qui est française et qui est fait partie
aussi des activités de la diplomatie
économique donc peut-être qu'il y a une
réflexion sur la mise en cohérence du
plan de décarbonation de Total
entreprise qui est maintenant une
discussion qui se passe pour toutes les
entreprises au niveau européen donc de
comment total va penser sa décarbonation
en même temps en cohérence et là
évidemment je me place que du point de
vue de la politique étrangère de ce que
la France pousse au plan européen et au
plan international donc voilà un peu les
peut-être les tensions qui peuvent exist
il y a un volet très
intéressant peut-être à à amener à votre
réflexion une bonne partie du
développement euh des énergies
alternatives nucléaires renouvelables
euh se peuvent seter aux au problèmes de
d'emprunt sur les marchés des capitaux
ou de financement de leurs activités
parce que effectivement c'est très
coûteux les entreprises pétrolières
n'ont pas de problème parce que leurs
fonds propres sont suffisamment
importants pour qu'il n'it pas besoin
d'emprunter c'est le problème
aujourd'hui des entreprises de l'éolien
particulièrement de l'éolien en France
et en Europe c'est le problème des
entreprises du solaire et c'est sans
doute même si c'est appuyé évidemment
largement par l'investissement public le
problème des investissements dans le
nucléaire il y a évidemment aujourd'hui
beaucoup de de financement privé hein
des banques des investissements c'est
une question qui est posée aujourd'hui à
différents niveaux euh de du financement
des activités des activités énergétiques
et là il y a il y a une distorsion
évidemment puisque les entreprises qui
investissent dans les énergies
renouvelables ou dans le nucléaire
lorsqu'elles ont besoin d'emprunter sur
les marchés des capitaux euh sont
évidemment dans un une situation
défavorable par rapport aux entreprises
pétrolières qui n'en ont pas besoin
voilà je vais m'arrêter
là merci mesdame on va donc d'abord
donner la parole au rapporteur ensuite
aux collègues qui voudront bien
s'inscrire de manière brève
naturellement monsieur le
rapporteur merci euh monsieur le
Président merci mesdames et encore une
fois désolé pour pour notre retard
y a deux qui son part peut-être de de
deux trois questions à Madame lequeré
d'abord euh vous nous avez euh
bien décrit la trajectoire française en
matière euh climatique
euh première chose un comment vous
arrivez à évaluer au fond
l'intégrité euh de nos émissions
l'intégrité de notre politique
climatique à partir du moment où
par exemple sur la question du
gaz nous sommes passés quand même à un
régime assez fort d'importation de GNL
notamment de GNL provenant d'Amérique du
Nord avec une composante gaz de schiste
que à ma connaissance nous sommes
incapables d'évaluer sérieusement
aujourd'hui ce qui pose à la fois un
problème de reporting pour nos émissions
en tant que pays et qui pose évidemment
un problème de reporting pour les
groupes énergétiques
concerné vous n'avez pas évoqué la
question aussi si on s'inscrit sur un
chemin de sortie des énergies fossiles
la question des subventions publiques
aux énergies fossiles dans quelle mesure
la France est aussi un pays qui continue
à subventionner les énergies fossiles
quand on sait
l'urgence d'en
sortir peut-être et dernier point madame
lequéret si vous me le permettez dans le
rapport de juin dernier vous évoqueiez
la faiblesse du reporting européen
international concernant les engagements
des acteurs non
étatiques qui fragilise l'action
publique donc qu'est-ce qu'il en est
évidemment regard par exemple de Total
énergie pour Madame Tubiana au regard de
votre expérience des négociations
climatique internationale évidemment on
se pose en permanence la question de
l'œuf et de la poule sur l'offre et la
demande d'énergie fossile Dubaï pour la
première fois a aborder explicitement
formellement la question des énergies
fossiles comment les états interviennent
au fond pour limiter les
moyens de la communauté internationale
d'agir de fait sur la sortie des
énergies fossil ou sur leur
réduction est-ce que vous avez été
surprise quand vous vous étiz à Dubaï
de de de voir le président pouyanet et
les membres de Total dans la délégation
officielle française enfin dernier
point les états de fait interviennent
pour faciliter
l'installation des groupes énergétiques
comme total dans des pays on pense au
Mozambique on peut penser à l'Ouganda on
peut penser à la papoisie
Nouvelle-Guinée et d'autres pays comment
fond au-delà des moyens de politique
publique pour réduire nos émissions de
gaz à effet de serre comment les états
parfois interviennent en contradiction
avec leur stratégie
annoncée merci mesame vous avez la
parole aussi brvement que possible parce
qu'évidemment là le champ est large euh
merci concernant les évolutions récentes
qui ont été prises en particulier suite
à l'invasion de l'Ukraine par la Russie
effectiv effectivement il y a eu des
points d'attention qu'on a soulevé dans
notre rapport très très important donc
déjà le point positif c'est que suite à
justement euh la guerre en Europe
actuelle la France et l'Union européenne
ont euh
re mentionner leur volonté de sortir des
énergies fossiles qui est la meilleure
façon en fait d'avoir une sécurité de
l'approvisionnement
énergétique par contre malgré cette
volonté il a a eu une redirection
justement au niveau de
l'approvisionnement de gaz vers le GNL
qui aimait plus de gaz à effet de serre
que le gaz naturel et donc et qui a
aussi un problème de stranded asset j'ai
oublié le la traduction vous m'excuserez
en français et donc qui est très très
problématique parce qu'on fait des
investissements qu'on ne pourra pas
exploiter jusqu'au bout et normalement
si on fait des investissements qui sont
pas B carbone il faut qu'il soit le plus
de le plus de de plus courte durée
possible pour qu'on puisse retourner sur
la trajectoire de baisse en émission et
pour le GNL si on construit des
infrastructures importantes ça ne sera
pas le cas le deuxième point d'attention
qu'on a soulevé c'est le développement
de de relations international avec des
produits avec des pays producteurs de
pétrole de nouvelles relations qui font
en sorte que ça rend plus difficile en
fait l'implémentation ambitieuse
d'objectifs climatiques euh la
subvention en France
euh aux énergies fossiles euh oui on a
fait un résumé de de tout ça dans notre
rapport la subvenion elle a été
particulièrement importante avec le
bouclier tarifaire qui était nécessaire
pour soutenir les ménages euh par contre
il faut que le gouvernement développe
des façons de soutenir les ménages qui
ne passent pas par les subventions
fossiles donc soutenir le les ménages
oui euh mais pas en payant les factures
d'énergie fossile mais avec d'autres
mécanismes qui sont aussi accessibles
euh parément au sein du budget vert on a
des investissements qui vont contre la
transition des investissements qui sont
euh effectivement euh des subvention euh
d'énergie fossile mais on n' pas de
trajectoire ou en tout cas très peu ça
se développe euh pour justement euh euh
euh remobiliser euh les soutiens euh qui
sont euh faits à travers ces subventions
mais avec des instruments qui ne sont
pas non plus euh une baisse de taxes par
exemple euh qui pourrait envoyer des
signaux négatifs euh sur l'engagement
des acteurs non étatiques c'est
particulièrement important euh ils ont
une place de plus en plus importante au
niveau international au sein des cops on
a des engagements sectoriels multiples
c'est des des douzaines d'engagement
sectoriel voir plus on a des engagements
aussi des villes et des acteurs privés
et ils sont très très peu suivi à
l'heure actuelle il y a pas à la fois il
y a des manques à la fois euh sur sur la
qualité de ces engagements et il y a des
manques au niveau du suivi donc au
niveau de la qualité
le les Nations Unies ont mis en place un
groupe
d'experts de haut niveau sur les
engagements des des entités non
étatiques qui a des recommandations très
très claires que les allégations de
neutralité carbone sont incompatibles
avec des investissements dans la
production d'énergie
fossile que la de crédit bon bon marché
peut pas remplacer les actions que
l'accent sur l'intensité énergétique ça
suffit pas il faut vraiment faire
baisser les émissions que l'action des
lobbyes aussi est incompatible que euh
et que l'évaluation volontaire euh qu'il
y a très plus d'applications qu'elle
doit qu'elle doit monter euh avec des
contrôles externes et des applications
de règles donc juste en appliquant euh
ces recommandations on pourrait vraiment
aller beaucoup plus loin euh dans la
redevababilité des acteurs qui sont
soutenus par
l'État je vais essayer de répondre
brièvement à vos questions monsieur le
rapporteur alors peut-être à propos de
ce phénomène nouveau dans les
négociations internationales de la
présence des acteurs économiques c'est
le cas depuis longtemps enfin non pas
dans les négociations puisque c'est des
gouvernements mais en parallèle et
c'était la philosophie de l'accord de
Paris de leur réserver une place pour
qu'ils puissent dire comment ils
allaient mettre qu'il s'engagent en
parallèle à changer l'économie bon il
faut se rappeler que malheureusement il
y a pas de solution avec des énergies
fossiles contre le pour la lutte contre
le changement climatique c'est
incompatible bon c'est souvent on a
quand même souvent l'impression qu'on
peut faire les deux mais non et on
commence aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
rappeler ça c'est très important pour la
première fois donc à à Dubaï on a pu on
a approvisionné en fond pour ce qu'on
appelle les pertes et dommages
c'est-à-dire les pertes irréversibles
que le changement climatique produit sur
les économies on le voit en France on
regarde le tourisme la santé
l'agriculture on voit déjà le coût de
l'impact du changement climatique au
plan mondial c'est évidemment plus élevé
je vous rappelle juste que les certains
assureurs ne veulent plus aujourd'hui
assurer un certain nombre de propriétés
à cause du risque du changement
climatique c'est déjà le cas en Floride
en Californie c'est en train d'arriver
évidemment aussi en juste pour dire
qu'il y a un coût économique que on ne
mesure pas encore bien mais qui vient
malheureusement plus rapidement que
prévu et du coup on a eu cette
contradiction à Dubaï entre les
entreprises pétrolières plus présentes
que jamais c'est un grand pays
exportateur de pétrole et de gaz dans
lequel la conférence se
passait très actif en même temps pour
dire qu'il voulait continuer à
développer la production et
l'exploration de pétrole et de gaz et en
même temps le la facture du coût du
changement climatique pour un peu vous
donner un peu l'atmosphère de cette
discussion total comme d'autres
entreprises étaient très présente euh
jusqu'au bout de la conférence présente
dans les délégations et il y a
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une réflexion au
sein du Secrétariat de la Convention
internationale des Nations Unies contre
le changement pour la lutte contre le
changement climatique pour essayer de de
traiter cette question des potentiels
conflits d'intérêts alors pourquoi j'ai
fait ce petit introduction au début
c'est que il a un conflit d'intérêt de
fait puisque lutter effectivement contre
le changement climatique pour qu'il soit
pas dangereux c'està- direire limiter
les températures comme c'est dans
l'objectif de Paris ça signifie arriver
à zéro carbone net en 2050 en moyenne
pour le pour la planète bien bien avant
pour les pays les plus développés et
donc il y a un conflit d'intérêt puisque
en même temps bien sûr que et ça se
comprend les les entreprises pétrolières
elle veulent continuer à produire du
pétrole et du gaz donc il y a un conflit
d'intérêt de fait fait qui n'a pas été
traité jusque- là parce que ça
n'arrivait pas il y avait pas de
présence particulièrement importante de
ces acteurs là à Dubaï le problème a
bien été très visible et on va y avoir
cette réflexion qui va s'accentuer avec
le lieu de la prochaine COP à Bakou en
Azerbaïdjan et qui est en pleine
discussion sur la réforme des processus
à l'UNFCC donc la France je crois
serait serait bien bien placé euh pour
montrer que on peut discuter avec les
entreprises de tel ou tel secteur mais
qu'il y a vraiment ce problème de
conflit d'intérêt qu'on traite par
exemple dans cette commission mais qu'on
voit discuter partout dans la manière de
gérer la politique publique et de donner
confiance euh notamment à ceux qui ont
délégué cette représentation c'est de
traiter proprement la question du
conflit d'intérêt et ce qui n'a pas pour
l'instant au fond ça avait pas été
anticipé maintenant le problème est sur
la table euh et on ne peut pas avoir des
entreprises qui disent qu'on veut
continuer à développer la production et
l'exploration de pétrole en est en
disant on a une place à la table des
négociations il y a une contradiction
malheureusement hein j'aimerais bien que
on puisse faire autrement qu'on puisse
avoir les deux mais c'est pas possible
donc on a vraiment ce problème
aujourd'hui devant nous euh il y a il y
a tout de même dans le
pardon j'étais trop longue
euh la France jusque là dans la
diplomatie économique française on
accompagne les entreprise he il est
classique que le Président de la
République emmène les grandes
entreprises dans tel ou tel pays c'est
classique ça fait partie du travail
normal il y a un moment où effectivement
il y a ce problème de contradiction
entre amener les grands acteurs
économiques et amener les grands acteurs
pétroliers il y a manifestement
aujourd'hui une contradiction si on
continue euh C cette diplomatie
économique encore une fois qui est
classique parallèlement il y a ce
problème des contrats à très long terme
donc Corine lequ a mentionné notamment
avec le Qatar on a pris aujourd'hui face
effectivement à l'agression russe des
engagements de très long terme avec des
pays exportateurs de gaz qui qui vont
nous exporter du gaz et ça va être très
difficile de se
dégager donc il y a aussi toute cette
problème de mise en cohérence qui est
probablement un sujet qui a pas été
encore ouvert et on devrait
ouvrir
avant de passer la parole à ceux qui la
souhaitent j'imagine madame que quand
vous dites que vous souhaitez qu'il n'y
ait plus par exemple total dans la
délégation française ça veut dire que à
condition que bien entendu aucune autre
délégation n'est d'accompagnement par
une société pétrolière ça doit être
l'équilibre pour tout le monde est-ce
que c'est faisable bien sûr monsieur le
Président c'est pour ça que je
réfléchissais on réfléchit sur dans le
cadre de la convention international des
Nations Unies sur les problèmes de
conflit d'intérêt la question de la
France est pas spécifique là merci alors
Monsieur tissau Merci monsieur le
Président je vais être bref pour ma part
j'auris une question principale sur les
importations de gaz de schiste faite par
le groupe Total et qui provient
notamment du Texas il y a 1700 gisements
en en activité et on sait son extraction
par fracturation hydraulique provoque
des risques de pollution des EAU mais
aussi de l'air à cause des émissions de
méthane et vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure un gaz dont l'impact sur l'effet
de serre est 80 fois plus fort que celui
du CO2 et si la France a prohibé son
extraction depuis 2011 c'est en revance
jamais interdit d'importer du gaz de
chiste exploité par ce biais et d'après
les données recueillies par disclose et
publié dans une étude de septembre 2023
420000 personnes seraient directement
exposé aux émissions toxiques libérées
par les forages de Total énergie au
Texas donc ma question c'est elle est
elle assez simple en fait pourriez-vous
nous préciser la réglementation en
vigueur sur le gage de schiste au niveau
européen et est-ce que le conseil pour
le climat s'est positionné pour
l'interdiction de telles
importations pardon sur il y a un
élément de réponse à votre question que
moi je n'ai pas je sais pas si Corine
l'a mais qu' on pourra sur le volet
européen vous précisez des choses parce
que sinon ma ma ma réponse serait trop
générale élément
additionnel
oui monsieur le rapporteur dans son
intervention a dit que la France
subventionner les énergies fossiles
quand on dit subventionner c'est de
l'argent qui est versé donc je voulais
savoir selon vous quels sont ces modes
de versement quels sont les sommes en
jeu et qu'est-ce qui qui peut être fait
pour corriger cela et pour éviter qu'il
puisse y avoir des subventions de la
France pour les énergies
fossiles je crois qu' il faudra vérifier
nos chiffres parce qu'ils ont bougé
entre 2021 2022 2023 puils ont augmenté
euh il y a différents canaux il y a les
subventions aux entreprises
typiquement au aux factures énergétiques
des entreprises donc ça c'est une
catégorie il y a le bouclier tarifaire
de la consommation des ménages et c'est
les deux grandes catégories à mon sens
qu'il faut regarder je n'ai plus pas les
chiffres en tête je je voulais je les ai
cherché je les ai pas trouvé hier j'ai
le chiffre européen en tête qui est
complètement effarant on a quasiment
dépensé
1000 milliards de subventions aux
énergies fossiles au plan européen au
total en
2022 et 2023 et la France dans la
moyenne les les grands les les les gros
pays qui ont beaucoup subventionné c'est
l'Allemagne et la France hein mais et ça
va du côté des entreprises comme du côté
très bien on a retrouvé les chiffres
donc j'ai retrouvé les chiffres donc là
on parle d'un total de pratiquement 12
milliards donc il y a les dépenses
fiscales qui ont été identifiées dans le
budget vert de l'État euh donc taxes
spécialisé dans les dromes gazol non
routiers dans les travaux Agricol col
gazol pour les poids lourds gazol non
routier pour les BTP donc ça c'est des
crédits de taxe don des taxes moins
élevé il y a d'autres dispositifs comme
l'absence de taxation sur le carburant
de l'aviation la différence de taxation
entre le diesésel et l'essence la TVA
réduite sur les billets d'avion et le
tau réduit de T ICPE pour le transport
maritime donc tout ça ça fait 12
milliards donc il y a une historique
c'est surtout quand c'est c'est des
crédits d'impôt des CR crédit de taxe
c'est pour le soutien des entreprises
l'historique elle est compréhensible
mais maintenant comme je disais dans mon
propos introductif ces soutiens doivent
pas passer par le financement des
énergies fossiles mais plutôt par
d'autres instruments
oui j'imagine que Monsieur folot voulait
dire est-ce qu'il y a des subventions à
la
production en France par définition pas
vraiment c'est plutôt des aides à la
consommation c'est c'est plutôt des
aides au ménag aux entreprises il y a
pas de subvention pour la production il
y a si vous me permettez monsieur le
Président une une réflexion pardon
intéressante c'est justement comment
c'est soutient par exemple le bouclier
tarifaire puisqu'on en parle beaucoup à
cause de l'électricité ces
jour-ci qui évidemment je comprends le
gouvernement a décidé de de d'augmenter
l'électricité un peu plus que que le
gaz on pourrait se demander si
effectivement les subventions à la
consommation enfin l'aide au ménage
enfin puisque c'est principalement de de
ça qui s'agit pourrait être plus
incitative dans le choix de solutions
moins carboné et on va avoir une grosse
discussion sur le développement des
pompes à chaleur qui une très bonne
chose en France pour le chauffage et
qu'en même temps évidemment un moment où
on va augmenter les prix deélectricité
plus que le gaz le gaz étant aussi un
des grands moyens de chauffage des
ménages français donc il y a une
réflexion nouvelle je crois à sur la la
sortie de ces de ces de ces subventions
un peu génériques qui ont été lié à la à
la aux évolutions des marchés de
l'énergie pour mettre ça en cohérence
avec la stratégie
bacarbone monsieur BAOS
oui merci monsieur le Président bonjour
mesdames le JC ou l'Agence
internationale de l'énergie rappelle
régulièrement que nous devons réduire
nos émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
l'ordre de 55 à 70 % d'ici 2030 pour
limiter leur champement global de la
planète à 1 degr5 c'est la base c'est
c'est c'est l'objectif les entreprises
continuent pourtant à exploiter les
égies fossil en contradiction manifeste
avec leurs objectifs c'est bien leurs
objectifs qu'elles ont annoncé
d'atteindre zéro émission net d'ici 2050
425 grands projets d'extraction ont été
ainsi listés en 2022 195 pour le pétrole
et le gaz de30 pour le charbon
l'entreprise Total ennergie retorque
sans cesse et on l'a on en a parlé tout
à l'heure euh répond à la demande
mondiale mais le lien entre l'offre et
la demande est très tenu et c'est ainsi
l'offre qui crée la
demande en tout cas on peut le
l'imaginer comme ça en tout cas le
penser comme ça aussi quelle politique
économique serait aujourd'hui pertinente
de votre point de vue pour revenir à une
trajectoire plus vertueuse que préconise
le Haut Conseil pour le climat au-delà
de traiter proprement le conflit
d'intérêt face à l'impunité affichée
clairement affiché par Total
ennergie je donne déjà un premier
élément de réponse et de complète
Laurence donc
la politique économique qu'on a
identifié jusqu'à présent mais c'est à
creusé du coup donc au niveau du budget
il s'agit vraiment de utiliser
l'approche du budget vert pour piloter
euh les les le budget de l'État vers des
actions qui sont vertueuses donc
justement ces 12 milliards que je
mentionnais tout à l'heure qui ont été
identifiés dans le budget de l'État il
faut avoir une trajectoire pour sortir
de ces instruments et aller euh aller
vers des investissements qui sont
complètement euh agnosties à aux
énergies fossiles ou qui sont sortis des
énergies fossiles euh le gouvernement
doit aussi trouver le financement euh
des euh 65 milliards de additionnels
pour les mesures B carbone et ça ça
implique de faire des décisions qui vont
répartir la part de ces financements qui
soit public et privé euh maintenant euh
il y a toute une opportunité derrière
pour orienter justement ces financements
pour que la part de ces financements
bénéficient aux entreprises françaises
au maximum euh donc il y a une
orientation de la production en France
pour qu'elle soit le plus bas carbone
possible pour qu'elle soit euh
souhaitable dans l'avenir donc on parle
de production de véhicules par exemple
on parle aussi de production alimentaire
euh pour encourager les entreprises
intermédiaires des industries
agroalimentaires à valoriser les
produits qui sont achetés en
France si on parle aussi au niveau des
obstacles au niveau de l'emploi on a
besoin de faire des actions pour
vraiment soutenir tout ça je me rends
compte que je suis pas complètement dans
le sujet là peut-être Laurence tu vas
pouvoir compléter sur
exactement total et
les
voilà le sujet forcément il rayonne sur
comme c'est une très grande entreprise
et un très gros secteur bon tout est un
peu dans tout il est vrai que les les
entreprises
pétrolières il y a un débat entre
l'Agence internationale de l'énergie et
le secteur du pétrole et du gaz un peu P
les leuf ils disent c'est en fait la
demande nous on fait rien d'autre que
répondre à une demande comment la
demande est générée bon il y a beaucoup
de effectivement d'abord on a vu ces
subventions fossiles dont on a parlé un
petit peu plus tôt il y a des aides à
l'installation j'ai oublié tout à
l'heure de parler des crédits à
l'exportation qui sont encore alors la
France je crois si mes souvenirs sont
exacts mais je revérifier s'est engagé à
stopper l'utilisation des crédits à
l'exportation pour les activités
fossiles alors je sais pas quand ça
devait être mis en place ça l''est pas
encore ça a été un engagement qui a été
pris après la conférence de Glasgow et
je crois autour de la conférence de de
en Égypte donc en l'année il y a 2 ans
et mais je sais pas quand ça doit être
mis en place mais il y a quand même
encore des crédits à l'exportation qui
sont liés aux activités fossiles donc
déjà du point de vue de la politique
économique on pourrait faire diff
différemment en en effet on a un
problème de besoin d'investissement dans
le secteur vert qui risque de ne pas
pouvoir vu les problèmes fiscaux que
nous connaissons bien sûr les règles de
stabilité budgétaire européenne il y a
toute une réflexion à avoir sur comment
ces investissements vert peuvent quand
même avoir lieu il y a quand même des
des éléments sur le maintien de la
demande alors structurellement
évidemment on le voit avec le secteur
automobile l'évolution du parc
automobile en vis-à-vis de véhicules
plus lourds et plus consommateurs a été
un gros facteur he d'augmentation des
émissions liées au transport euh et là
c'est une politique aussi alors là qui
est privé bien sûr mais mais l'état
aussi a une influence sur euh les euh
les soutiens euh aller vers des
véhicules plus propres euh il y a une
autre question pour lequel il y a aussi
une un élément
de dire de de narration si on peut dire
qui n'est pas exactement sérieuse les
entreprises pétrolières disent qu'elles
peuvent arriver à la neutralité carbone
parce que elles vont pouvoir capturer
leurs émissions au moment de la
production au moment de premier moment
de l'extraction et de la production
euh en réalité quand on regarde les
chiffres il y a eu un rapport de l'IPCC
enfin du GC en c'est ancien et c'est
c'est remisou enfin avec des données
récentes ne peuvent représenter qu'une
très petite partie on peut capturer et
stocker puisque si finidemement il faut
garder ensuite le carbone dans le sol
euh
là où on peut le socker et c'est une
très petite partie donc il y a il y a
une
une non réalisme dans les plans de
décarbonation de ces entreprises pour
lequel il y a pas il y a pas eu de de
pour l'instant de d'évaluation sérieus
au plan de la politique publique sur ce
cette idée que les émissions pouvaient
être supprimées du secteur pétrolier
c'est toute la discussion d'aujourd'hui
qui va qui a lieu cette année qui aura
lieu l'année prochaine pour pour montrer
que ça n'est pas une solution et
d'ailleurs ça fera partie du débat du du
13 et 14 février de l'agence
internationale pour l'énergie alors il y
a un autre élément c'est que les les
instruments économiques qui sont liés
aux fossiles donc notamment les taxes
que payent les
consommateurs on a toute une réflexion
aujourd'hui sur le fait que la
production et l'exportation de pétrole
ne contribue pas au financement ni des
dommages qui sont engagés ni
éventuellement du développement de
solutions alternativ et c'est vrai que
on a eu toute une discussion vous vous
en souvenez peut-être mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs de de de la taxe
sur les surprofits pétroliers au moment
de 2022 et de de l'invasion de l'Ukraine
et il se trouve que Total pe très peu de
taxes en
France il il localise beaucoup de ses
pertes donc peut-être il faut avoir une
enquête un petit peu spécifique
là-dessus et du coup il y a peu de peu
d'instruments d'incitation de la
politique
française vis-à-vis pour pour
inciter une entreprise comme Total à
être plus cohérente sur la
diversification de ses activités en fait
c'est le coût le coût du pétrole est
porté par les consommateurs et
évidemment ne donne aucun signal
économique à l'entreprise elle-même et
donc ça c'est aussi une réflexion qui
est d'ailleurs engagée aujourd'hui au
plan international et que le président
Macron a lancé lui-même à
doubï très bien merci beaucoup
mesdames prochaine réunion lundi avec
bonheur et nous tâcherons d'être plus
respectueux des horaires
merci
euh